Warmest year ever, most snow ever, and a megadrought
for the United States...
But you know what guys?
Global warming isn't real.
HAHAHAHHAHAHA
people who are ready to listen and also climate
trolls
Let me tell you a story about how global warming,
or climate change, if you prefer, is happening.
It's science.
It's proven.
Deal with it.
But, just because we know it's happening doesn't
mean we know the long term effects.
In light of conservative officials from the
Great State of Florida unofficially discouraging
government and educational institutions from
using the words "climate change", "global
warming" or "sea-level rise," we thought we'd
see how that was working out for everyone.
Luckily for us, and Florida, the Pacific Northwest
National Laboratory analyzed data running
back 2000 years using ice core information,
and weather data from the 19th and 20th centuries.
They projected temperature changes in 40 year
chunks.
As there was relatively little greenhouse
gas release for most of our history, the temperature
fluctuated, but essentially remained the same.
But looking from 1971 to 2020, their model
shows warming an increasing speed.
It's gonna get warmer, faster; changing the
Earth in unpredictable ways we've never seen
before.
2014 was the hottest year on record, beating
2010, which trounced 2005 which had previously
won over 1998… then 2013, 2003, 2002, 2006,
2009, 2007 and 2004…
And that's the top ten hottest years since
we started checking in 1880.
In fact, 2014 was the 38th year in a row with
"anomalously high" global temperatures.
According to the U.S. National Climatic Data
Center, part of NOAA, if you're under 30,
you've NEVER LIVED through a year where the
average surface temperature was below average.
People who are 60 have had a completely different
EARTH than we have, in terms of the climate.
The oceans were at different temperature,
the weather was less severe and the extremes
were more tempered by those changes.
Not to be outdone, 2015 has already been a
big year for climate change.
A study in Science Advances from NASA and
Cornell outlined a timeline for the coming,
"megadrought."
Using models built from observing climate
trends, their study says we have an 80 percent
chance of experiencing a drought worse than
anything we've seen in North America since
the 12th and 13th centuries.
Humans can act to decrease the CHANCES of
the megadrought, but man-made global effects
are exacerbating the drought already gripping
the American West.
Not to mention the CRAZY snows.
The Northeast has had record snowfalls this
year, and as the globe warms, snowfall increases.
We can all remember a bad storm, or a hotter
summer, but luckily, data doesn't rely on
the terrible human memory.
The U.S. Global Change Research Program does
a National Climate Assessment every year,
and they found a 71 percent increase in "very
heavy" Northeastern Storms from 1958 to 2012.
It's not just storms though, a study in Geophysical
Research Letters, found volcanos will increase
as Icelandic ice melts, increasing surface
heat, and further spewing greenhouse gases
into the atmosphere.
CLIMATE CHANGE, YA’LL!
From November 2012 to December 2013, over
9000 authors published over 2200 papers and
only one of them disputed man-made global
warming.
One.
And that author blamed the sun, which is hot,
that’s true.
But while the sun's been constantly tossing
energy at us, the levels of CO2 in the atmosphere
in 2013 were 142 percent higher than a hundred
years before.
So we need to face it; the climate HAS changed!
Scientists believe it's possible to curtail
the effects of man-made global warming, but
you already knew that.
Now we have to decide what do about it.
Pollution and climate changes were something
ancient people never had to deal with, but
DRUGS -- that's a different story.
Our new sister show Seeker looks into the
hallucinogenic habits of ancient humans, and
those of tribes that survive to tell us about
those habit still today.